welcome everyone to cannabis
101 what you need to know to answer your
patients
questions and feel good about it
to give you a little history on where i
come from
in 2013 i thought
cannabis was a gateway drug in 2014
after being requested to step into the
space
and problem solved some kids that were
having
intractable side effects from
chemotherapy
i investigated cannabis and by the end
of 2014 i was already working
on a patent here's my disclosures
i am involved in both research and drug
development
in the cannabis industry today
so our learning objectives for this
uh presentation i'd like to give you an
overview of cannabis and its
constituents and review some of the most
important
families in our phase 1 or cytochrome
p450
elimination system
impacted by phytocannabinoids review the
different delivery methods
of cannabis and their impact on
onset and duration of effects and review
common side effects of cannabis and how
they relate to route
of administration now you all should
have access to the slides and references
so that you can go back and review
details that you find
interesting my goal is to expose you
to important information and challenge
you
as healthcare providers to investigate
this very powerful and safe adaptogenic
herb
now i think cannabis is a beautiful
plant
on the right you're looking at a
cannabis leaf and on the left
your work you're looking at what's
called a bud
or a cured trimmed
form of the cannabis flower
which is it's in its uh prime consumable
form
now you're looking at a couple pictures
one on the left
looking at santa cruz tsunami
a four to one ratio uh
marijuana plant and to the
right you're looking at a hemp
cannabis plant that has less than 0.3
percent
thc in it to
the untrained or trained eye
today it's very difficult to tell the
difference between
uh different forms of cannabis that be
marijuana
or hemp so let's take a look at what
those terms
really mean both are cannabis sativa
l but they're regulatory terms and it's
based on the content
of thc marijuana
being defined as uh
containing point greater than 0.3
milligrams per gram of thc
and the dry weight of the plant and
remember that
still today federally marijuana
is a schedule one drug and by definition
that means there is no recognized
medicinal value
and it's highly addictive hemp on the
other hand
is defined as having
0.3 milligrams per gram or less
of thc in the dry weight of the plant
and in the amended farm bill of
october of 2018
congress defined hemp finally
as an agricultural commodity
both the plant and all of its uh
components
and in states that have defined
a uh usda program
[Music]
which makes hemp growing legal in that
state
by definition if it's legal in the state
then it's federally legal by default
now that was october of 2018. we're in
march of 2020
and the federal government still has not
rolled out
their federal program
now cultivar versus
quinovar versus strain plants
did not have strains bacteria and fungi
do
but strain is a common term that is
talked about especially in dispensaries
cultivar which is an equivalent
proper term to strain
is generally defined by the grower
based on smell appearance and
physiological
effects now common terms used
are sativa indica and hybrid
sativa typically a taller a skinnier
plant and the physiologic
effects are just described as more
energetic
and giving someone a head high if
they're consuming thc
indica is a shorter squatty plant
broader leaves and generally is
gives an effect of being more relaxing
and more of a body high now greater than
95
of the flower market today
is all hybrid or mixes of sativa and
indica
and there's a few varietal names that
you may have heard
jack herrer sativa dominant
blueberry and indica dominant and
catatonic
hybrid chemovar on the other hand
is a term that is defined by
multiple chemical components
which can be standardized identified
and most importantly will need to be
used in order to ensure reproducible
cannabis effects physiologic effects
that patient can expect
now the endocannabinoid system we could
spend
two hours talking about i'm only got
a few slides and so this is an area that
i implore all of you to investigate
the endocannabinoid system regulates
physiological and cognitive processes
and is probably the most important
physiologic
system establishing and maintaining
health and homeostasis it's involved in
fertility pregnancy
prenatal and postnatal development
appetite pain cessation
mood memory neuro protection
inflammation
endocannabinoids play an important role
in the neurotransmitter in the immune
system
mitochondrial function and they have
anti-proliferative anti-inflammatory and
anti-metastatic effects
and back in the 80s when i was in
medical school
we were told that the runner's high was
from endorphins
but later we have found that it's
actually
uh in our endocannabinoid system and
uh anandamide one of the
endocannabinoids now endocannabinoids
are endogenous lipid-based retrograde
neurotransmitters inandamide
and 2ag for short
are two of those endocannabinoids
thc mimics
anandamite and cbd
mimics 28g
so this is in our endocannabinoid system
has kind of a a key in a lock system
the receptors that were first discovered
cb1 and cb2
[Music]
are g g protein coupled receptors
that are on the plasma membrane
of each cell in our body
cb1 is mainly found in the central
nervous system
although scattered throughout the body
cv2 is mainly in the peripheral system
but is also found centrally
cb1 receptors were first cloned in
1990 and cb2 receptors were first cloned
in 1993.
now we have cannabinoid
receptor dependent and cannabinoid
receptor
independent mechanisms that
endocannabinoids as well as
phytocannabinoids engage in
and this is a list of some of those
receptors and you can review
on your own leisure so let's look at the
phytoconstituents
that come out of the cannabis sativa
plant
they all start as an
acid form and the main acid
that all other cannabinoids are derived
from
is cbg this chart
shows you the enzymes also involved
in generating the main
phytocannabinoids
now when the cannabis flower
is harvested it contains
mostly acid but temperature
and light will help the decarboxylate
or the conversion of the acid
form of that cannabinoid to the neutral
form
we're looking at the two main
cannabinoids on the left thc and on the
right cbd
notice that these acid form
and neutral form have
physiologically active
value and at the bottom
one of the terpenes beta-caryophyllene
is a direct cb2 agonist and has
its own direct anti-inflammatory
activity
so again we're taking a look at the two
main
uh phytocannabinoids thc
and cbd thc being a partial
agonist of both the cb1 and cb2
receptors
activation of the cb1 receptor
centrally is where we get the effect
of the intoxicating effect or that high
that's associated
with thc in the neutral form
not in the acidic form and
reported effects are listed there
cbd is an allosteric modulator
of cb1 and cb2 receptors it's an
inhibitor of
pha and an agonist
of the serotonin and vanillinoid
receptors
now mary's work out of israel he's done
tremendous work this is looking
at a heat map an lcms
approach and i apologize for the size of
this
but on the top of this
heat map lists 36 cultivars
and on on the left side
it's identifying the different
cannabinoids
now there's been 144 cannabinoids
identified to date and over
500 physiologically active
substances in the cannabis plant
so when we simply talk about thc
or cbd it's remarkable
that you can see
you know dark areas are high
concentrations
light areas are low concentrations
there is 10 different thc
delta 9 types there is 10
cbd types just identified
in a portion of this heat map
looking at terpenes which are the
aromatic substances that give
plants their unique scent and flavor
there's three categories mono dye and
sequest terpenes
most cannabis plants can possess
up to 200 terpenes but there's typically
five to eight dominant terpenes
terpenes possess their own individual
effects and many times dominate the
subjective
experience of a cannabis user
now leafly.com is a good internet
source that has tried to standardize
some information
both with color and with um
with category and so uh
this is one of the ways that they
present
how for this example white tahoe cookie
it's an
indica dominant
cultivar and it's showing the dominant
terpenes that are color coded
and you can find those colors associated
with a calming effect mercin being
on the far left and uh energizing effect
with uh terpenoline
on the right
here is an information wheel that
they've created
that looks at terpenes boiling points
aromas
the effects found some of the medical
benefits
uh that are associated with different
varietals
and so the colors green being hybrid
red being sativa dominant
and purple on the outside of the circle
being indica dominant
this is where patients are going to be
coming to you with questions
and this is some of the resources that
they've been looking at so
that's why i'd like you to become
familiar
so looking at a basic single dose
pharmacokinetic curve
c max separates the
absorption from the elimination phase
the therapeutic range is defined between
the minimum effective concentration and
the
minimum toxic concentration
t-max is the time it takes to reach
c-max
and the time to onset
is defined as reaching the minimum
effective concentration the therapeutic
range defines
efficacy cannabis pharmacokinetics fit
into this model
but many of the therapeutic endpoints do
not
because they are biphasic
inhalation is the most common
and preferred route to date and is also
the most
published route of administration in the
literature
now bioavailability of thc depends on
the way
of smoking and there is a number of
different ways to inhale
and what's remarkable is
even with control of both
content temperature
inhalation volume length of time
breath held you still see
between a six and twelve
fold difference if you look on the far
right hand side
thc range twelvefold difference
from one individual to the next
with the same controlled inhalation
method
of any given dose of cannabis this is
pretty profound and why it makes it so
difficult to know exactly
what someone is going to experience and
many of these influences are genomically
based so this is controlled
inhalation and clearly this is
an example of not a controlled
inhalation method
typically
100 nanograms per mil is considered the
concentration of thc in the blood
that causes in the intoxication but
again
this is really dependent on the
individual individual
and their tolerance
um sorry about that so let's quickly
look at
um the first uh and
a number of the fda approved
cannabinoids that marinol was the first
being fda approved back in 1985
so there is actually
a lot of data on uh
you know synthetic uh starting with
dronabinol
synthetic thc this is a soft gel capsule
that's swallowed
what's interesting is you have an 80 to
90 or 90 to 95 percent absorption
rate but only 10 to 20 percent gets into
the bloodstream
here's another formulation of dronabinol
which is an oral solution and an ethanol
propylene glycol
base taking a look at the first
synthetic
thc analog which is nabillon which is
consumed orally as a capsule having very
similar
bioavailability
the first phytocannabinoid
to hit the world market
by gw pharma with sativex or nabixomol
this is a approximately one-to-one ratio
of thc to cbd and it is delivered
as an oral mucosal spray so this gives
us some
good pharmacokinetic data on
both thc and cbd
it's uh sativex is currently still in
phase three
clinical studies here in the u.s
but it is currently available
in at least 36 countries
that have already approved it through
their fda
equivalent federal
drug approval process in
june of 2018 the first
phytocannabinoid extract from marijuana
epidiolex another gw pharma's
uh product was approved
for uh uh
the use in seizure
or treatment resistant seizure disorders
again this is a cbd product
it is marijuana derived a phyto
[Music]
extraction and is not a synthetic
now to appreciate the difference in
formulation
of the same drug take a look at
thc detection in plasma
after 15 minutes compared comparing
marinol and syndros marinol being
swallowed as a capsule
and syndros being a liquid so
besides at 15 minutes
less than 25 percent of marinol
is being
[Music]
detected in the plasma where 100
of syndros is there's also a substantial
intra individual variability
uh between marinol and cinderoast if you
look down at the bottom
line
now looking at the pharmacokinetics of
terpenes
kohlhert in 2000 did a great review
of the and looked at the published data
in both humans
and animals there are more than three
thousand compounds that have been
described
but limited studies on most
on the clinical side there's been a lot
of
published data on essential oils
in well-established in vivo studies
looking at copd acute bronchitis ibs
and the rest pharmacokinetic
data though on
terpenes and turbinoids is very limited
and really the bottom line is that
the analytical methodology is
the rate limiting step to the quality
and reproducibility of data
so in order for us to really appreciate
the value of terpenes
therapeutically in cannabis we're going
to have to do a much better job
of establishing standards in
analytical methodology the main
drug interactions involved with cannabis
involve
the phase 1 elimination system or the
cytochrome p450 system
more than 60 percent of prescription
medications
are metabolized by this
phase one elimination system in our
liver
all phytocannabinoids inhibit certain
cyp 450 enzymes and
are involved mainly three families the
cyp
2c 2d and 3a
families cbd is the strongest inhibitor
of all of the phytocannabinoids studied
to date
now what's important to realize is most
studies show
little clinical impact when using
normal therapeutic dosing of
cannabinoids
many of the studies that are looking at
the
theoretical impact use
10 to 400 fold higher
concentrations that are found clinically
now there's a few drugs that clearly
have an
impact um
drug drug interaction with cannabis and
it's important to identify
those and know how to work with that
clearly warfarin is one of those drugs
so in this study looking at 85
this was a review article looking at 85
articles there was three
eligible articles that were identified
back in january of 19. one
looking at the in vitro effect
of thc and its inhibitory effect on cyp2
c9 and warfarin which
uh is one of the metabolic pathways for
warfarin
and two in vivo one uh
a male uh uh consuming
marijuana uh one weren't sure about the
dosing but there was two uh situations
where his inr was raised
above 10 and there was some associated
bleeding
one of the medications for epilepsy
epidiolex a 30
reduction in warfarin in order to
maintain
that therapeutic inr value now what's
frustrating is the authors suggested
that if the patient was on warfarin they
should be warned against cannabis use
we warn patients about the use of dark
green leafy vegetables
we tell them if you're going to consume
them
which many of them contain the antidote
to warfarin
which is vitamin k we just say
stabilize your diet there is no reason
why a patient can't be on warfarin
and cannabis as long as that
adverse event is being managed properly
by following inrs
now another significant
drug interaction with cannabis
is with clobazam which is a
anti-seizure medication for treatment
resistant cases
and clovisam and
its active metabolite norclobazam
can have a profound impact on
uh or blood levels
and so if cannabidiol
or cbd is being used
it's very important to monitor both
clobexam
and norclobazam at four and eight weeks
of starting therapy
and this study they in a great
randomized crossover
study they looked at three different
drugs
looking at those different pathways that
are known
to be inhibited mainly by cannabinoids
the 3a 4
the c the 2c19
are our main areas and uh
looking at rifampin an inducer
ketoconazole an inhibitor of 3a4
and a pramizol a ppi
that is an inhibitor of the
2c19 pathway what they
found is that if there is a patient
on cannabis and on
another prescription medication that
is influencing either by inhibitory
or inducing the three a4
pathway you should take a look at that
impact in potential drug drug
interaction
project cbd is a fabulous reference for
healthcare providers
and patients i strongly recommend that
you visit this site
and learn the science as well as the
real life stuff involved with cannabis
therapeutics
it's also available besides english and
spanish
portuguese and japanese
so let's look at the adverse effects
using
cannabis this is a
partial list if you look
closely that you'll find that many of
the reported adverse
events from cannabis are actually
treatment endpoints or
for instance insomnia
is is one treatment endpoint the
cannabis is used for
all the time anxiety panic attacks
very valuable in these areas
factors that influence these adverse
events
include the formulation route of
administration
the experience and tolerance of the
patient
any comorbid conditions that they have
drug drug interactions the genomics of
the individual
whether there's product contamination
and whether
the products have been misbranded or
mislabeled so knowing what to use
and how to use it is the key to avoiding
almost all adverse events
now dr marku is going to be talking
about inhalation and vaporization and so
i'm not going to spend much time on this
but i did want to just make you aware of
some of the key points surrounding
vaporization hazards one of them is
temperature and its influence on
breaking down
for instance terpenes in this particular
study
and where mercy and lymonine and linolol
will break down under certain
temperatures
it can form isoprene and then ultimately
some very toxic
byproducts like benzene
temperature is important and what the
experts say
is it should for dabbing or
combustion it should never go above
378 degrees celsius
now recently
there's been a huge amount of concern
over e-cigarettes and uh
it seemed like this just all of a sudden
started
popping up in 2018 and 2019
but this data has been available um
as early as 2017
looking at the carbonyl compounds
produced from vaporizing cannabis oil
using thinning agents
we should never see a thinning agent a
flavoring agent
ever being used in a in a cannabis
product
uh cannabis oil that's being vaporized
or being used
in or added to
flour what we find
is that the products that
have been studied can produce some
pretty toxic
things polyethylene glycol
uh for instance um vitamin e
acetate even mct medium chain
triglycerides
polypropylene glycol
can produce some pretty nasty stuff pg
and peg can produce acetaldehyde
and formaldehyde which there is no
safety you know exposure
to those toxic products and peg
is most
important in producing
other carcinogens like one for
dioxane and ethylene oxide when it's
heated
so bottom line is
never smoke an e-cigarette don't use
flavoring agents to inhale
and don't ever expose yourself to a
cannabis extract
that's vaporized and what's
really good about regulated markets
today is that
none of the products that you find in a
dispensary today
unlike what's found in the black market
have
diluents that can cause these problems
now looking at the disconnect
between patient physician and cannabis
regulatory framework surrounding
schedule one drugs has always separated
the patient
from the physician and that is because
if a physician prescribes a schedule one
drug
like cannabis that is aiding and
abetting
a federal felony and that is one of the
problems
that we're still dealing with with
physicians having
a dea registration and
operate in a state that allows for both
medical and or adult use
consumption so what
i'm giving you an example of nevada but
every state should have statutes that
protect
a licensed health care professional from
both
their licensing boards
for any disciplinary action and i
implore you to take a look at these
areas
there's always a qualifying condition
when there's medical and or
well medical use
adult use doesn't require a qualifying
condition
and there's different qualifying
conditions based on
each state
there's generally a process that a
medical patient
needs to follow in order to
get the id necessary
when medical patients unlike adult use
patients
get registered that registration
generally allows them to avoid taxes
and it also gives them access to
products that are
much more concentrated or in a larger
quantity per package than an adult use
a patient can get access to
in each state there is generally
regulations
associated with possession and
consumption
and typically medical patients will have
access
and be able to carry more product on
them
at any one time or purchase more product
than adult use and generally there
is rules for consumption and so
you need to know what those state
and county rules are because they vary
between
state and between county and sometimes
even city
now the national academies of sciences
engineering and medicine
18 years after their first report did an
extensive review of the literature
january of 2017
actually that's when it was published it
looked at over a hundred
it uh ten thousand research articles
all human uh based
so they removed all the in vitro
or in vitro [ __ ]
let's start again
no worries this is 50 still right
ready to start yeah okay
count you down five four
three two
now the national academies of sciences
engineering and medicine
18 years after their first report
did an extensive review of the
literature in
january of 2018
and looking at only human data
in over 10 000 research articles came up
with a hundred research
conclusions from this information
they defined level of evidence as
conclusive
substantial moderate limited
or no or insufficient evidence
what is remarkable is that they found
conclusive evidence for the use of
cannabis
in nausea and vomiting associated with
cancer chemotherapy
in chronic pain in adults in spasticity
and ms
chronic pain in adults this is we've
been in an
opiate crisis for years now
and still the federal government
doesn't recognize cannabis as having
a valuable place in medicine
still today with their continued
schedule one category
this in 2019 looked at
over 800 000
registered patients in 20
states including washington d.c
and found that 85.5 percent of the
conditions for which the patients are
licensed to use medical cannabis
either had substantial or conclusive
evidence of
efficacy here's another
information wheel from leafly
that lists symptoms and conditions
and again this is a resource that many
patients may even bring into your office
and ask you questions about
now the reported medical applications
that cannabis are brought
this is just a partial list in our
clinic in huntington beach we find
greater than 60 percent of patients are
looking for
improved pain control and or to get off
of their opiates anxiety
is another very
high indication for the use of cannabis
as well as many of the other indications
that have been
discussed uh
in this study of autism uh
children with autism spectrum disorder
uh
what is remarkable uh to me besides
this being a great resource for
references
is that in this 53
children group
the side effect or adverse event profile
of
someone's or a change in appetite we're
all mild but to look at self-injury and
rage hyperactivity
sleep a profound problem
with uh autism spectrum disorder
and just overall improvement these are
high
60 to low 70 percent
improvements in the use of cannabidiol
in this patient population
profound routes of administration
now there's different ways to use
cannabis and
you can think of almost any
pharmaceutical
there is a product that has cannabis
in it it's available so whether it's
vaporization combustion
smoking like a joint edible forms
capsules sublingual tinctures buccal
absorption
we'll go over some of these and the
importance of
why all of these different forms
should be always made available
to a medical patient
vaporization or the combustion
of plant material is still
the most frequently used form of
administration of cannabis today
generally we look at a quick onset
within
one to five minutes and a duration which
is short
generally one to two hours again it
depends on the device some devices
like the docent to the right here
can deliver a specific dosage
of cannabinoids that are
defined and allow a patient
to know exactly as well as the
healthcare provider to know exactly what
the patient is consuming
and the dose in order to see what that
patient's outcome is
now there's different uh standardized
delivery systems that are out there
around the country and the world
that helped deliver uh very specific
doses of cannabinoids
by inhalation this is one study
that looked at six patients
and the important thing to look at
is that using the volcano device which
controls
dose volume of ventilation
you still see a c max
of 30 to
180 nanograms per ml this is the same
dose
the same inhalation volume and looking
at six different patients and having
that
variability in the amount of
cannabinoids measured
this is a study
looking at over almost 3 000 patients
all above 60 years 65 years old
mean average age of 74.5
with pain and cancer they looked at
a after six months of cannabis use
how they were the respondents
improved in their condition
which is profound their study found
that uh therapeutic use of cannabis
is safe and efficacious in the elderly
population
it may decrease the use of prescription
medications
including opioids i
urge you to take a look at that study
now there's edible forms of marijuana um
many states will define different
[Music]
edible forms statutorily
differently from state to state but
generally
edibles should be considered a food
product
so cannabis has been infused into
something
that you eat onset of action
can be one to two hours up to
even four hours depending on what
the patient ate before they consumed the
cannabis
and if you've eaten a heavy fatty meal
it could take four hours
for gastric emptying to occur duration
of action is generally six to eight
hours
edibles are where you hear the most
extreme experiences where uh
consuming a brownie for instance waiting
an hour no effect
eating another serving of a brownie
still no effect and then four hours
later
the person is so high that they're
very uncomfortable they're intoxicated
so it's uh again
a much more difficult
route of administration to control
here's a study that you can look at
looking at a 10 25 and 50 milligram dose
of thc
and the blood levels that it that were
observed
in both the metabolites and looking at
thc
and it's clearly not linear
tinctures sublinguals buccal absorption
this typically is very
dependent on formulation
and placement in the mouth so buccal is
between
lip and gum sublingual is typically
placed
underneath the tongue and the problem
with assuming that one
product a tincture or a sublingual
solution
is equivalent to something else that
possibly is delivered buccally
you can't make an assumption unless you
know
the specifics about the formulation that
the patient is taking
so if one person has a
you know not a good outcome
with the sublingual don't assume
that all of those products out there are
going to be the same
depends on how they administered it
whether they held it
in their mouth for 5 to 15 minutes
before swallowing
if you put a sublingual in your mouth
and you swallow it within 20 30 seconds
which most
patients do because they don't like the
taste then all of a sudden you've turned
oral oral mucosal absorption
into an edible and
as such you're going to get a much
slower onset
of action and a different duration of
action
most sublingual products on the market
and the cannabis space
are
sublingual oils and they have a
15 to 45 minute onset of action in a
duration of three to four hours
here's some examples of of a couple
published products
tablets or a fast melt
tab here's an example
of misbranded products
in a pharmacy you would not find
a sublingual solution like drift away
labeled as a tincture tinctures are
typically an
ethanol-based solution and not a coconut
oil-based solution
here's a quick study looking
at the impact of minor cannabinoids
this patient had
relatively intractable seizures um
treatment-resistant seizures at the
point that he was seen
in given a thc cbd
sublingual solution with no terpenes
based in mct
oil he was having eight seizures a day
uh within 24 hours he
had seizure free days that continued
until he went back to get another refill
from his local dispensary of what he
thought was the same
301 sublingual solution
and what occurred was
immediate loss of seizure control and
seizures starting again
so the dispensary
[Music]
staff member that helped this patient
was also aware that they changed the
cultivar from a diamond og to a lemon
haze in that particular product
he went back made more of the diamond og
extract and again the patient
regained seizure control
and if you look there's in the
again in the phytocannabinoids that we
are looking at which may or may not have
a causal effect
cvga and cbc were really the only
significant difference between those
transdermal patches and creams
there's just tons of products out there
the majority of them do not produce a
psychoactive effect if it contains thc
in the neutral form
there is cb 1 and cv2
receptors all over our surface of
our body and many people do
get great relief from the topical
application of products
it's important to know or follow a few
guidelines for patients
new to cannabis you always want to start
low go up slow one to five milligrams
of of cannabinoids are typically
considered a micro dose
if the patient has never consumed
cannabis before
generally after a single dose of a micro
dose
you want to wait three hours before
consuming more
especially if it isn't edible like the
gummies that you're seeing to the right
remember that cbd is an antidote
to the thc intoxicating effects
in our clinic we never start a cannabis
naive patient
on any thc containing cannabinoids
it's always started we always start them
on a cbd
product between one and three days see
how that impacts their symptoms
and then add thc at night generally in a
1.25 to 2.5 milligram dose remember
start slow start low and go
up slow you can always add more
but it's hard to take away what you've
consumed
that is causing undesirable
intoxicating effects
laboratory testing is critically
important
and all states that have
medical and or adult use require
testing and we're looking at potency
and any risk associated with pesticides
residual solvents heavy metals
and microbiological or mycotoxin
contamination
this is an example of some of the
equipment that's used
lcmsms is is really the
a great way to
have analysis and this is an example
of a certificate of analysis
uh this has to be this is in reference
to an eliafe
um flower
that is uh being tested out of
nevada so it you can
that you should never buy a product
whether it's in a dispensary or it's a
cbd
product on the market without
a certificate of analysis for every
batch
and product that is that you're
considering to buy
if it doesn't come with that don't buy
it
so something to think about cannabis
is an adaptogenic herb and it's disease
state modifying
adaptogens are substances that help you
arrive at homeostasis cannabis has a
huge therapeutic range and no
ld50 cannabis is a federally scheduled
one drug still today politics and
special
interest not evidence-based medicine
results in its prohibition and schedule
one drug status
the endocannabinoid system is profound
and it drives our homeostasis
cannabis has been used for thousands of
years in multiple cultures
cannabis was one of the top three
prescription drugs
prescribed by physicians in the u.s
before 1932
it was in the pharmacopeia from 1850 to
1942.
so my recommendation is educate
embrace and empower and with that
i leave you with dr burgess and dr
crowley
in a field of legal hem